can i tell the story of when i had
dinner with your family without you
is that in london oh my lord
okay i have dinner with aki and a whole
family without a key there
can you please give them context
so aki's family was staying uh in a
hotel in london but i think it was quite
exciting i mean hotels in london are
very expensive yeah but i wanted to give
it as a gift for them yeah so they were
staying in a nice in bank
quite a nice area of london quite posh
yeah meanwhile these two were just
staying at my house
not even in the same city yeah yeah
quite far away
it's like the airport was gatwick so
it's like 30 minutes up
30 years yeah so i i had connor kind of
helping my family i felt so bad because
uh it was like in the middle of uh
july or august it was during the heat
wave yeah
and i took them on the underground on
the central line which is basically like
the yamanote
yeah i took them on the worst busiest
train with all their luggage it was so
hot and i was like i'm so sorry i could
tell aki's dad was like having a mental
breakdown
because it was so hot yeah so much
luggage and there's no ac in there
like a really bad back yeah he was
losing it i was trying to help carry as
much luggage as i can i'm like are you
good you're good
you want to hydrate yeah
so like i first like the central line so
i took them all the way to their hotel
and i think it's thanks they were like
let's
let's invite connor out for dinner so i
just had a dinner
meanwhile chilling in brighton
joey was like on my hammock or something
yeah i remember conor texting me he's
like i'm so sorry my mom's watching this
too
like hello your food is lovely that you
prepare for you
but yeah i know i remember you texting
me being like dude
even more kudos if you're a youtuber or
streamer because like at the moment they
find that out they'll keep like do you
did you guys
give me your analytics right now no like
did you guys watch harry potter
like did you guys watch harry potter you
know ron's dad like being really
obsessed with um like muggles yeah
that's my parents like with youtubers
and streamers
that's
that my mom like she got uh she texted
me being like oh my god belle delfina's
back and i was like
what like i watched her sex tape
she was like how do you think her only
fans is going i was like i don't know
i don't care dude like yeah so my
parents are very like
on point i feel that whole like
welcoming side of your parents
especially the like i feel
ties in with like kind of how the you
know the filipino like mentality yeah so
my
family funny enough we actually are all
introverts but when you meet them you
wouldn't think so it's mainly because if
you're a friend
of mine then they'll more than be happy
that to open it up but i feel like
we're giving me food i was like that's
that's the filming
and her mum was checking up on me more
than my mum was
like what's going on i don't know what
it is about southeast asian parents or
just families where
they try to solve every [ __ ] life
problem yeah
by offering food aki's mom has bought me
more underwear and socks than my own
kids
that says a lot yeah my mom she always
like delivers uh just some stuff from
overseas and she always gets like six
bags of like cheetos
like every time when i was a kid i'd
visit my family
i'd even be like oh you don't seem like
you're eating well here have more food
oh are you feeling well
here have more food oh you're not
feeling well it's cause you haven't
eaten happy yeah yeah yeah and if you're
fat then they'll just be like oh you're
getting so fat eat
yeah which is weird you know like i
don't know if it's like in any other
family i just noticed with a lot of
asian families
being called fat is a good thing because
it means that you're being
you're you're being fed that's that's i
feel that's a specifically southeast
asian thing yeah yeah yeah it's like oh
you're so
fat now oh my god do you have boyfriend
like it's
yeah so it's always because that's not
how it works in japan like even even if
you lose weight
or like gain muscle you're like damn you
got fat i was like
i just gained muscle but all right
thanks thanks for destroying my
self-esteem
there's definitely one thing about asian
culture that's like very different from
the west where
people aren't afraid to comment on other
people's weight yeah right yeah where
it's a very like
you know it's a very sensitive topic in
like if you comment on someone else's
weight
in england or the us especially but here
in here in asia it's a free-for-all yeah
you know
it's like we're just we're just saying
what we're seeing right it's like yeah
yeah you just you just meet like the
amount of family reunions or family
gatherings i've got i've gotten to i've
been too sorry
and people just the first thing they say
is like damn you're getting a bit fat
aren't you
and i'm like ma i'm [ __ ] satisfied
what are you talking about
i remember you're the fittest guy i
remember i went
when we were staying at garn's place and
then like i don't eat spicy food which i
know is like really blaspheming
uh in southeast asia it is yeah i know
sorry and but i remember like
your mom was gonna make us food and then
she asked like is there anything that
aki can eat and you said oh she can't
eat spicy food and then she's like
i'm making curry what do i do so she
tried to she tried to work around it and
it was like those amazing [ __ ]
spiciness like dance mom dead ass came
up to me and was like i have
never made a thai card without each
other i don't even know if it's gonna
taste good
at all like i've never done this before
yeah they're still really good
i had never had like those like what is
it like those noodles it's like a
southeast asian
it's like a rice noodle yeah it's like a
rice noodles i can't remember the name
right now it's [ __ ] good
thai people are fuming right now yeah
yeah huh it's not very certain
yeah what's even the english name of
that like i don't know
rice noodles right it's like these yeah
it's just like these piles of like
noodles and then you just take them and
dip them in the curry
i think i don't know it's on the screen
mood on you can figure it out i don't
know i don't know what it is but
every every southeast asian is just like
[ __ ] my own language i don't know at
what age i realized there was more than
one type of noodle
wow yeah how did you like as a white man
as the token white man
like i i feel like your view of noodles
was like my view of bread
because like for me every day yeah every
bread was just the same
i'm sure i'm saying this and everyone in
europe just like dies a little
what bread is so varied yeah there's
definitely way more types of bread than
our noodles though
no no
we're gonna we're gonna have to ashley
can you look up to see there are
more types of bread than there are types
of noodles
i think there are more types of noodles
no there is not yeah we'll figure that
out
no pasta no pasta's not pasta's lost
yes i'll have a i'll have a noodle
bolognese for his
gosh well at least you don't try to eat
it with chocolate we're gonna start
world war three or that one coming up
yeah
we should stop talking about food we
should stop talking about food